على شاطئ البحر الأسود ، لا
يمكن وصفه إلا بأنه قصر على بعد 190
ألف قدم مربع من الجو ،
يمكنك رؤية بيت الشاي بالكنيسة
والمدرج ، ويقال إنه
حلبة هوكي تحت الأرض مع منطقة حظر طيران
ومنطقة محظورة للقوارب
وفقًا لذلك.  في تحقيق
أجرته مجموعة زعيم المعارضة الروسية المسجون أليكسي نافالني في العام الماضي ،
زعموا أن هذا القصر المذهل الفاخر
المناسب لملك
تم بناؤه لفلاديمير بوتين ، هذا القصر
هو رمز
ومصغر لروسيا بوتين الذي لم يعد يرى نفسه على
أنه  موظف حكومي كشخصية منتخبة
يرى نفسه قيصرًا
كملك من نوع
ما ، وبعد ذلك تعرف أن الروسي يستحق بالطبع
قصرًا لا تستطيع CNN التحقق بشكل مستقل من
اتصال بوتين بالقصر
وينفي المتحدث باسم بوتين أن الزعيم الروسي
يمتلكه  أو يقول أي قصر ماريا بيفسيك من
مؤسسة مكافحة الفساد التابعة للبحرية
إن لديهم دليلًا على أن
مصادرهم ووثائقهم تشير جميعها إلى القصر
كمثال على هو  عندما يثري الأوليغارشيون
رئيس روسيا بشكل فاسد ،
فقد تم دفع الأموال من قبل الأوليغارشية
الروسية من قبل الشركات المملوكة للدولة
الروسية ، حيث سُرقت أموال من أشخاص عاديين
من الروس
وتم تحويلها إلى بناء هذا
الشيء الفظيع على البحر الأسود
وفقًا للتحقيق
والمبلغ عن المخالفات الذي جاء  إلى الأمام ، جاءت الأموال
الخاصة بالقصر من
شركة صناديق استثمار روسية طلبت
تبرعات خيرية من
الأوليغارشية الروس ،
وهناك شائعات حول كون بوتين
أغنى رجل في
العالم وقد يكون
من الصعب
جدًا محاولة فهم
ما هي ثروته  وحيث
ترددت شائعات عن قيمتها أكثر من مائة
مليار دولار ، يدعي بوتين رسميًا
أن شقة بمساحة 800 قدم مربع بها عدد قليل من السيارات
وراتب متواضع في عام 2020 تقدر قيمته
بنحو مائة وأربعين ألف
دولار ، لكن دخله الرسمي غير
ذي صلة يقول مراقبو روسيا بوتين
يسيطر على روسيا من خلال تحديد من
يحصل على المال ومن لا يمكنه إدارة
الأعمال التجارية ومن  يخطط للربح وكيف
يتم تمرير الثروة ، فهو لا يحتاج إلى أي
أصول مدرجة باسمه ، كما يقول
الصحفي توم بورغيس ، كل ما يملكه عندما
يسأل أنه أقرب إلى شيء مثل
الأب الروحي ، لكنهم في النهاية
مدينون بكل ما
لديهم لرئيسه وبنقرة واحدة  من
أصابعه كما أظهر في الماضي ،
يمكن لبوتين أن يأخذ كل شيء من
الأوليغارشية مهما كانت
ثراءها ومهما كانت نفوذها ، فهي
تعتمد عليه في نهاية المطاف في
محاربة النظام للتدخل في السياسة
ومواجهة غضبه من القلة الروسية المنفية
ميخائيل كوتاوفسكي الذي
أدين بارتكاب جريمة.  قضى التهرب الضريبي والاحتيال
10 سنوات في سجن روسي ، كما قال بسبب
عدم لعب لعبة بوتين التي يدعي أن بوتين
خطر بجنون العظمة ويجب
إيقاف
جميع حسابات جميع الأوليغارشية
الذين يعملون كمحفظة بوتين ،
يجب أن يشعروا جميعًا بالألم بشكل
صحيح  الآن ويجب أن تستمر حتى
تنتهي الحرب
العقوبات المفروضة حديثًا من الغرب
جعلت الأمر صعبًا على العديد من
المليارديرات الروس.  للقيام بأعمال تجارية
خارج روسيا ، فإن الحسابات المصرفية لليخوت
المجمدة داخل روسيا ، يظهر الاقتصاد
علامات الانهيار ، لكن التخلص
من قبضة بوتين الوحشية على السلطة من خلال
الاقتصاد سيستغرق وقتًا
من أفعاله ، يعتقد المراقبون أن
استراتيجية بوتين تتجاوز
الثروات الشخصية التي يريدها لإعادة بناء
روسيا.  قوة عظمى
وعليك العودة إلى الأيام القيصرية
لفهم أن مجرد إلقاء نظرة على بوابات
قصر بوتين المزعوم
نسر أرضي ذهبي برأسين رمز
لروسيا على غرار النسر المتوج ذي
الرأسين والموجود فوق البوابات  من
القصر الشتوي الذي كان ينتمي إلى
آخر قيصر روسيا رسم غريفين سي إن أتلانتا